bah oui c'est reparti les cafetières
donc nouvelle saison nouveaux
chroniqueurs
ah oui d'après des études récentes
études alors battre on l'a démontré
l'espérance de vie d'un nouveau
chroniqueur dans l'émission serait à peu
près équivalente à celle d'un homme
faisant son footing sur l'autoroute mais
ça t'arrive 6 quand même à s'imposer
comme matthieu delormeau un à qui on
avait mis une boule en cuir dans la
bouche de la première émission l'hadopi
matthews découpe ses nouveaux camarades
entre émerveillement et consternation le
plus beau si son père s'est perdue quand
il regarde ce qui se passe autour de lui
du miel
il m'a fait rage de ça depuis tout à
l'heure le miel à la pancarte est partie
au cp
marquez et nora qui connaît les missions
ne peut même pas lui répondre cd oui je
suis pas avec toi je n'ai pas vu je
connais pas avait tourné au cp c'est une
vraie révolution pour mathieu qui je
vous le rappelle était avant sur arte
pour ceux qui ne connaissent pas la
gamme actuelle était sur nrj12 avant le
mag et ouvre quel chien sera à la
hauteur
quand il était habitué à une certaine
rigueur journalistique avec cyril
hanouna c'est la descente quoi là cyril
buvait une cannette et d'un seul coup il
a eu une idée de génie
j'aime trouver un jeu parce qu'ils m'ont
mis une canette
mais ils ont tellement cacher je vous le
dis je un morceau de la can est celui
qui trouve ce que c'est la canette voilà
sur twitter #cannes est
et ben je lui lance son poids genband
planète alors nous on habille ses
fulgurances mais pour les nouveaux c'est
plus dur pour garder la tête admiratif
de matthieu delormeau pendant que s'il
crée à stains et ben sur lyon
samedi le maquillage génératif bresse et
sannois et au bout du rouleau est au
bout du rouleau le mail va s'habituer à
pour nous l'arrivée de mathieu c'est une
embellie art et enfin quelqu'un qui
réfléchit dans l'équipe
en fait celle qui parle le mieux des
qualités de mathieu senora jeu oublié
mon endroit j'ai bossé dans la tête tout
dans ce type
comme moi bon nrj12 et nt1
les lectrices sur nrj 12 maintenant au
moins on est sûr que mathieu va pas y
retourner et pourtant vous allez voir la
tentation est grande
au total mais au comptoir et 12ème en
peignoir le kite en peignoir dans les
rues raconte sa vie
olala mont batur je sens que c'est une
très bonne recrue pour les quatre tirs
c'est énorme c'est la nouvelle idole et
surtout ne croyez pas que mathieu est
malheureux chez nous au contraire il a
trouvé une nouvelle famille et avec
cyril un nouveau papa toujours prêt à
lui donner des précieux conseils et est
vrai un chemiser tandis que tu te
conforter chemise comme avec d'aussi
puissant maire de seysses
6 kg près c'est pour vous alors mathieu
c'est aussi une sensualité débordante il
a essayé de draguer et nora cyril
valérie bénaïm et ils se comptent pas
s'arrêter là regardez il est maire
nommé pour tout le monde a commenté
non